[Musica]
quest'oggi mi piacerebbe parlare di
viaggi in particolar modo mi piacerebbe
parlare di Slow Travel oggi vanno di
moda questi inglesismi per dirla in
italiano lo Slow Travel è un turismo di
tipo lento responsabile se ci sono un
paio di concetti che mi piacerebbe
enfatizzare a riguardo dello Slow Travel
sono quelli di consapevolezza e
sostenibilità il viaggiatore lento
responsabile si rende consapevole del
fatto che il proprio viaggio abbia un
impatto sull'ambiente circostante
riconosce l'importanza della diversità
culturale in atto e in questo senso
cerca di preservarla valuta la diversità
culturale come una ricchezza e con
sostenibilità il viaggiatore lento
responsabile si propone di preservare
questa continuità culturale in atto e di
sostenerla non solo diversità culturale
ma anche ambientale proprio oggi
sostenibilità ambientale abbiamo la
percezione vivere in un ambiente molto
fragile e lo Slow Travel si propone
appunto di sostenerlo di preservarlo
negli anni ho viaggiato con una sorta di
dilemma interiore che mi ha accompagnato
lo potrei definire il dilemma del
viaggiatore dove Da una parte c'è questa
irrefrenabile curiosità che mi ha spinto
mi ha spinto andare a esplorare gli
angoli più remoti del pianeta mi ha
spinto andare a cercare l'ignoto di
andare oltre in luoghi che non conoscevo
da una parte c'è questa curiosità che
però mi sono reso conto che un po' cozza
un po' va a scontrarsi con una
consapevolezza che il mio essere
fisicamente in un posto che non è quello
in cui sono cresciuto va un po' a minare
questa diversità culturale di cui
parlavo rischia un po' di inquinare lo
status quo e negli anni ho cercato un
po' di risolvere questo dilemma fino a
che poi non ho trovato una sorta di
soluzione personale al quale poi
arriverò più tardi nel corso
dell'intervento
Io ho sempre viaggiato con un pizzico di
nostalgia ho sempre avuto l'impressione
di arrivare sempre troppo tardi nei
posti Nei miei viaggi che sono sempre
viaggi perlopiù in paesi meno
civilizzati in paesi in via di sviluppo
ho sempre cercato un po' di trovare
questo shock culturale che così mi
appassiona mi da questa sorta di
adrenalina mi piace sempre andare a
vedere il mondo come era possibilmente
come probabilmente i nostri nonni
potevano vederlo mi piace sempre andare
a ricercare quella diversità culturale
che proprio mi
mi fomenta
in particolare questa filosofia di in
particolar modo questa mia filosofia mi
ha portato a viaggiare tanto in Africa
orientale dove si parla la lingua
swahili c'è una parola swahili con la
quale se viaggi in paesi come la
Tanzania o l'uganda si verrà
costantemente bombardati questa parola è
musungu musulngo non fa altro che
definire il l'uomo bianco il viaggiatore
di tipo prettamente occidentale quello
che mi ha affascinato principalmente di
musumegue la sua etimologia
Come si può definire per dirla in
inglese la definizione più precisa di
musum può essere quella di spinner
spinner significa qualcosa che gira una
sorta di moto
incessante agli occhi magari
dell'ugandese dell'autoctono era
impensabile che un uomo si trovasse lì
dall'altra parte del Pianeta così Per
curiosare apparentemente senza un senso
senza una meta un vagare spaesato No un
po' perché l'autocto non si sognerebbe
mai di intraprendere un viaggio per
esempio non so un olandese non si
sognerebbe mai di andare a fare un
safari in Kenya o di scalare il
Kilimangiaro soltanto per il gusto di
dire ho scalato la montagna più alta
d'Africa Certo un po' perché
Mancherebbero i presupposti economici
per viaggiare un po' perché manca quella
percezione culturale legata al viaggio
che è proprio tipica di noi occidentali
quello che ha scatenato in me questa
etimologia di musungo che poi è stato
anche un tema affrontato in Uganda una
domanda che mi hanno personalmente posta
è quella perché viaggi perché sei qui e
in tutto il tempo ho cercato proprio di
dare una risposta significativa sensata
a questa domanda Nel mio percorso di
viaggi ho sempre cercato appunto di
superare il dilemma e di trovare un
proposito sensato al perché al mio
viaggiare
oggi se dovessi lanciare un messaggio
visto che comunque in questa platea
Immagino che quasi tutti un po' chi più
chi meno ci sentiamo un po' dei
viaggiatori No siamo viviamo in un mondo
dove i numeri a livello turistico
andranno inevitabilmente a crescere ci
saranno sempre più persone che
inevitabilmente si muoveranno per il
mondo sia per scopi legati al viaggio e
al turismo e quindi in questo senso
vorrei esaltare la platea viaggiare in
maniera assolutamente consapevole e
responsabile ovvero dobbiamo viaggiare
con parametri nuovi che tengano in
considerazione l'impatto che il nostro
viaggio ha sull'ambiente circostante sia
a livello di continuità culturale sia a
livello propriamente ambientale
dunque c'è una risposta a tutto ciò c'è
un modo che veramente c'è un modo per
cui riusciamo a viaggiare cercando di
non avere un impatto negativo nel mondo
Anzi magari potremmo cercare grazie ai
nostri viaggi di creare un valore
aggiunto proprio le comunità che ci
stanno ospitando dovremmo ragionare
proprio con una mentalità di viaggiare e
nel momento in cui viaggiamo Noi siamo
ospiti in un altro in un altro paese
probabilmente non c'è una risposta
univoca a tutto ciò posso provare però a
raccontarvi quello che ho fatto io e
come la mia evoluzione dei viaggi a un
po' superato il dilemma di cui vi
parlavo e ho trovato un modo consapevole
e sostenibile di viaggiare
ad esempio qualche anno fa lavoravo in
Olanda avevo tutto ciò che mi serviva
per vivere la mia vita così agiata ma
sentivo che mi mancava qualcosa
quello che ho deciso di fare quindi a
quello di lasciare il mio lavoro e di
mettermi in viaggio avevo deciso di
iniziare un viaggio
che mi avrebbe portato da qui da Spezia
a Palermo tutto ciò ho deciso di farlo a
piedi
proprio perché volevo approcciarmi a
questo viaggio lento proprio perché
volevo ricercare qualcosa di nuovo e di
diverso e in questo senso l'approccio la
filosofia del viaggio lento per me è
stato ha fatto la differenza nel senso
che mettermi in viaggio mi ha creato
quella condizione fisica e mentale
giusta per poter prendere poi le
decisioni più importanti della mia vita
cioè cosa lavoro cosa veramente voglio
fare nella mia vita Ecco il turismo
lento per me lo Travel è stata in
qualche modo Una una risposta se sono
qui la persona che sono oggi e se faccio
quello che veramente mi piace fare lo
devo anche a questa filosofia di viaggio
che mi ha permesso appunto di trovare la
mia la mia strada
parliamo quindi di turismo lento di Slow
Travel ci sono in particolar modo
secondo me tre concetti se dovessi
spiegarvelo mi piacerebbe Infatti usare
questi tre pilastri dello Slow Travel
cominciamo a parlare con di connessione
il primo concetto che mi viene in mente
sottolineare proprio quello delle
connessioni umane questo insieme di
scambi e condivisioni tra il viaggiatore
e le popolazioni locali che creano
valore creano questo scambio
in particolar modo credo che sia di
fondamentali importanza andare a
conoscere prima di mettersi in viaggio
la cultura che andiamo a visitare
proprio per accettare per abbracciare la
diversità culturale anche se ci sono
possono essere differenze di tipo
politico religioso credo che sia
importante avere questa mentalità di
accettazione c'è un dato che mi ha fatto
un po' riflettere che è quello che il
70% degli italiani Considera la propria
cultura superiore alle altre Ecco io
credo che dovremmo muoverci da questa
percezione
gerarchica culturale verticale a una di
tipo orizzontale nel senso non esistono
culture superiori o inferiori alle altre
Ma esistono semplicemente culture
diverse dalle altre no in questo senso
dobbiamo
abbracciare la diversità dobbiamo
valorizzare percepire come una ricchezza
via Terra via terra un concetto che a
livello di connessioni locali Secondo me
c'entra tantissimo via terra è un po'
questo concetto che da sempre mi ha
affascinato Nei miei viaggi ho sempre
cercato per quanto possibile ovviamente
di muovermi con mezzi muscolari come
possono essere per esempio le mie gambe
la bicicletta
ho viaggiato anche in canoa vi ho
parlato appunto del viaggio da Spezia a
Palermo a piedi viaggio che poi io ho
ripetuto in bicicletta Insomma quello
che mi piace del concetto via Terra di
spostarsi fisicamente con i piedi per
terra e questo ci porta anche una
mentalità molto umile responsabile è
proprio quello che ci fa mettere allo
stesso livello delle popolazioni che
andiamo a visitare per me che magari mi
piace viaggiare in posti così Meno
civilizzati in paesi in via di sviluppo
l'ho ritenuta una cosa importantissima
proprio per mettersi allo stesso livello
dell'interlocutore Viaggiando per
esempio che ne in Tanzania l'uomo bianco
spesso ha visto come fonte di aiuto di
denaro il fatto di viaggiare via Terra
tipo in una condizione di metterti allo
stesso livello e c'è di più si crea una
sorta di senso del bisogno nei confronti
del viaggiatore da parte della Comunità
locale che spinge proprio questi
interazione questo scambio mi è capitato
appunto di essere Mi hanno offerto cibo
acqua quando magari in condizioni
normali questo non sarebbe non sarebbe
accaduto quindi a livello di connessioni
umane e assolutamente importante
conoscere la cultura che andiamo a
visitare per poterla rispettare e Non
commettere errori gravi che portano
distanza tra il viaggiatore la comunità
locale posso farvi un paio di esempi per
esempio
qualche anno fa ero a Zanzibar che
c'erano dei turisti in bikini nel centro
storico Ecco in un paese di matrice
islamica questa ritenuta particolarmente
offensivo oppure nel classico tempio
indiano durante una cerimonia turisti
che scattano foto col flash Anche questa
è ritenuto particolarmente offensivo il
conoscere una cultura ci aiuta e ci
porta a superare questi questi errori
che possono creare una distanza una
barriera insormontabile tra chi viaggia
e chi vive nel luogo ospitante
il primo concetto Appunto È quello di
connessioni e un altro concetto che mi
preme sottolineare e può essere anche
insomma un invito poi logicamente
questo questo invito può essere rivolto
a tutti voi non c'è bisogno di dover
viaggiare necessariamente dall'altra
parte del mondo in posti poverissimi per
mettere in pratica ehm questo paio di
consigli e un secondo tema che mi preme
sottolineare quello della sostenibilità
economica cioè il veicolare il nostro
denaro in maniera consapevole nella
comunità quando viaggiamo abbiamo questa
incredibile opportunità di creare valore
anche attraverso i soldi che spendiamo
Questo mette in moto un potenziale
circolo virtuoso oggi si parla molto di
Experience no esperienze che si fanno in
viaggio Quando si vuole viaggiare si
cerca sempre di fare quelle attività
tipiche del luogo no ecco nel momento in
cui viaggiamo È importante che queste
attività vengano diciamo così fatte con
direttamente con i soggetti locali
Organizziamoci in modo tale da prenotare
direttamente in loco laddove possibile
le nostre esperienze in viaggio per
esempio in Tanzania ho scalato il
Kilimangiaro e mi è capitato poi di
sapere che alcune persone che erano
intorno a me avevano speso Magari il
doppio per lo stesso tipo di esperienza
proprio perché magari in mezzo c'erano
altri investitori stranieri tour
operator i quali possono essere
perfettamente evitati sia per
risparmiare noi sia per creare questo
circolo virtuoso attraverso i soldi che
spendiamo lo stesso può valere per
esempio per l'alloggio magari evitiamo
di prenotare alloggi con
intermediari quando magari potremmo far
risparmiare le strutture soldi soldi
Preziosi Quindi cerchiamo di avere la
mentalità di creare un circolo virtuoso
e di far finire i nostri soldi nelle
mani giuste per esempio viaggiando in
Africa orientale c'è il concetto dei
Community Camp Cosa significa Community
Camp è un posto solitamente un campeggio
un posto dove vanno magari turisti a
stare
e la gran parte degli utili derivanti da
questa attività vengono redistribuiti
tra la comunità locale Questa è un
ottimo modo per creare appunto il
circolo virtuoso di cui di cui vi ho
appena detto
dopo il concetto di connessioni umane e
rispetto della cultura dopo il concetto
appunto di sostenibilità economica c'è
un terzo e ultimo concetto che mi
piacerebbe
enfatizzare che per dirla con un
inglesismo che oggi va un po' di moda a
dire la verità poi il concetto è stato
un po' abusato negli ultimi anni è
quello di Less is more però mi pareva
che fosse particolarmente calzante con
quello che stiamo dicendo e con i
principi stessi dello Slow Travel di che
cosa possiamo fare a meno che cosa
possiamo identificare come lessismo
intanto mi viene in mente meno kg nello
zaino consiglio a tutti di partire il
più leggeri possibili Oggi viviamo in un
mondo fatto di comfort e di comodità e
io vedo il viaggio come un modo per
staccarmi da questa
straordinaria comodità per abbracciare
il discomfort il discomfort che lo vedo
come proprio quell'attitudine necessaria
per accrescere il proprio senso di
responsabilità in viaggio che tutta
quella serie di decisioni che dobbiamo
prendere che ci creano una sorta di
autostima un senso di responsabilità e
ci fanno veramente
crescere
meno di che cosa possiamo fare a meno
intanto a me piace anche parlare di meno
luoghi nello stesso intervallo di tempo
abbiamo la mentalità molto spesso che
vogliamo viaggiare e vedere più posti
possibili io ritengo che tante volte
vedere meno posti ci fa vivere quei meno
posti che vediamo con una profondità
diversa
io in questo senso predico un po' la
qualità a scapito della quantità inutile
in una settimana a cercare di vedere più
posti possibili quando magari
concentrarsi su un luogo ce lo fa vivere
in maniera migliore
ho una struttura ricettiva spezia molto
spesso arrivano ragazzi molto spesso si
arriva da Genova e a molti ragazzi
Genova proprio non piace e alla mia
domanda quanto tempo hai passato a
Genova la risposta è un giorno Beh io
credo che sia molto molto difficile
andare ad apprezzare una città Comunque
è difficile come Genova in un solo
giorno Per cui il mio invito è passare
più tempo in meno posti proprio per
apprezzare ciò che ciò che c'è anche
perché lo Slow Travel il fatto di
viaggiare senza foga senza rincorrere un
posto dietro l'altro senza rincorrere la
storia su Instagram Ci fa dilatare il
tempo quindi viaggiando abbiamo la
percezione di avere più tempo e di
vivere più serenamente quel poco che
quel meno che vediamo e di poterci
dedicare più a le famose connessioni di
cui vi ho appena parlato
All'inizio si parlava un po' della
domanda perché viaggino che mi è stata
mi è stata propriamente posta quando ero
quando ero in Uganda Ecco ora a distanza
di anni se devo e posso rispondere a
questa domanda perché viaggi
in tutti questi anni ho cercato appunto
di dare un po' un senso un significato
ai viaggi la prima volta che ho messo il
naso fuori dall'Europa era in India
ormai più di 10 anni fa già arrivato
all'aeroporto mi sono reso conto come I
Cinque Sensi che finora avevano
percepito determinate sensazioni ne
hanno Cominciate a percepire
completamente diverse alle quali erano
stati abituati Mi ero fatto un'idea di
evoluzione civiltà che in quel momento è
completamente svanita mi sono reso conto
appunto che esisteva un mondo con delle
logiche di comportamento e di pensiero
completamente diverse dalle nostre e ne
sono stato particolarmente affascinato
qualche anno dopo invece sono andato a
lavorare nell'Isola del Borneo
all'equatore in Brunei c'è una natura
meravigliosa una giungla rigogliosa
verde quello che mi piaceva fare per
andare a fare alcune camminate o corse
nella giungla mi è capitato più di una
volta di essere completamente
sopraffatto da
dalla bellezza naturale della foresta e
se devo appunto trovare un nesso è
proprio questo Cioè stupirsi e portare
lo stupore che si prova durante il
viaggio nella realtà quotidiana secondo
me questa proprio l'essenza del viaggio
portare lo stupore nella nostra
ordinaria realtà saperci stupire saperci
meravigliare
ora immaginatevi di essere invitati a
casa di amici a cena ognuno di noi cosa
farebbe principalmente sicuramente
cercheremo di rispettare l'etichetta
della casa il galateo magari arriveremo
con un dono con un gelato Proprio per
essere accomodanti con chi ci ospita
Ecco il mio invito per voi oggi è
proprio questo quando siete in viaggio
comportatevi esattamente come se foste
invitati da qualcuno considerate di
essere ospiti in un altro paese questo
ci aiuterà tutti a vivere il viaggio in
maniera più consapevole e più
sostenibile
Grazie
[Applauso]